hi diddly ho neighbors and welcome to an
extra giggity-inducing episode of
versus hosted by me mark ellis you may
remember me from such shows as robocop
versus terminator and nicholas cage
versus john travolta but today
it's an all-out battle between two
amazing american animated programs
the simpsons versus family guy in one
corner you have homer marge
bart lisa maggie and the rest of the
springfield gang
okay fine a few shelbyville stragglers
might show up taking on quahog's finest
maybe not finest family peter lois brian
stewie chris and shut up meg
plus their lovable neighborhood cohorts
it's the show that completely
revolutionized animation
television and comedy in one fell doe
taking on the cartoon that loves
controversy just as much as it adores
cutaways
like that time i got fired from being a
stormtrooper
no we don't um have that footage
apparently here's how we'll determine a
winner
round one ratings round two tomato meter
slash
audience score round three iconic
characters
round four best episodes and then we'll
do a wild card round to settle the score
and i'll be honest family guy is
probably hoping to win
a round here it might be my most watched
show but the simpsons is
i'd say the goliath of tv shows but it's
more accurate to equate it with being
the whole damn bible sorry i swore
it changed everything is it too late to
team up family guy with south park and
rick and morty
poor peter thought battling ernie the
chicken was rough this is gonna be a
doozy
let's get it on i'm saying the simpsons
suck
why you
round one rating times have changed and
so has the ratings metric is a measure
of success for a tv show
nowadays the best of the small screen
would do well to get a fraction of what
it used to
the advent of streaming services and
physical media have all but guaranteed
that both of these shows will never
again reach their previous heights
unless the simpsons finally decides to
hang it up which they haven't through
over
30 seasons of comedic brilliance it was
those first few years of being a new and
somewhat controversial show in the early
1990s that saw its biggest ratings boom
through its first four seasons the show
never dipped below
21.8 million viewer averages per season
and as the 90s carried on the simpsons
found a new cruising altitude around the
13 to 15 million viewer range
by comparison this past decade has seen
its average ratings peak
at 5 million sets of eyeballs per year
and it's been in this last 10 years at
family guy has emerged as a credible
ratings competitor to
its um older brother slash rival show
while its most recent season saw returns
of just 2.65 million average viewers
family guy is only a few years removed
from consistently earning
five to seven million folks tuning in
each and every week
and remember that 1990s there were
ratings boom ushered in by the simpsons
yeah family guy only caught a tiny
glimpse of that in its heyday
its first season in 1999 is still the
best
ratings performance in the history of
the show and having 12.8 million viewers
on average
largely bolstered by a clutch premiere
after super bowl 33.
that episode it was much better than the
football game preceding it
if only the minnesota vikings could have
made that chip shot field goal
all right and nobody's blocking family
guy does draw some blood in this round
based on its resurrection after
languishing in multiple time slot
switches
fox had pulled the plug on the show
entirely until the first wave of dvd
sales came through
fans showed up in such force to own
their new beloved animated series that
the network
gave it another chance at life which has
continued to this very day
but sometimes humble beginnings make for
a more rock solid foundation
while family guy had a super bowl
audience and weeks of playoff hype to
capitalize on
the simpsons started out as a crudely
drawn segment on the tracy allman show
but once it earned itself a spin-off
series the rest was history
today the simpsons total average viewers
per season across all 32 of them
is a mind-boggling 11.3 million
meanwhile family guy's 19 seasons have
earned a very respectable
6.2 million average viewers per year
like i said it's going to be tough for
the griffin gang to get a point in
today's matchup
and it's not going to arrive in the
ratings category they put up a tough
fight
and even if we were tied up to this
point the simpsons could lob in the fact
that
their 2007 movie raked in over
million dollars worldwide ratings are
nice cold hard cash
is better and that cast knows a thing or
two about money the simsoys take round
one
and it's one to nothing
round two tomato meter slash audience
score
family guy does have a puncher's chance
at evening the score here
simply based on the fact that we're
talking about both critic and audience
metrics in this round
the master supported them once by buying
so many dvds that the studio took notice
can they come through in the clutch once
again to lay a finger on bart's
butterfinger
it's possible okay what the
family guy's first three seasons are all
fresh according to the audience score
all landing right at 75 percent across
all seasons the griffins stay fresh at
62 percent
their overall tomato meter average is
even more brilliant landing at 72.2
percent
that number is largely bolstered by
seasons 11 and 16's perfect 100
rating pretty impressive for a program
whose inaugural season
is rotten on the tomato meter at just 46
percent
so how about those springfield residents
who've been going strong so long
we can remember when it was the fashion
to wear an onion on your belt
they're beloved like a lot across the
board both the audience score and tomato
meter averages best their pesky upstarts
from quahog
as all 32 seasons of the simpsons
averaged 76
on the audience score and 85 percent on
the tomato meter
the audience apparently loved seasons
six through eight the most
as all three averaged 97 percent if that
still doesn't impress you
then i hope you're sitting down seasons
1 through 10 of the simpsons
are all a perfect 100 on the tomato
meter
except for season 9 which for some
reason landed at 67 percent
was that the who shot mr burns season
what gives
the team got close to another perfect
season in 2017
as they landed at 99 fresh on the tomato
meter
okay so the simpsons has another big
lead but before peter joe cleveland and
quagmire head to the clam to drown their
sorrows i will
point out that family guy has a higher
floor than the simpsons
remember how i said 46 percent was
family guy's first season on the tomato
meter
that's as low as they got for all 19
seasons thus far
meanwhile the simpsons fell all the way
down to 33 percent for season 24.
is that the one where maggie no no
that's that was i almost ruined the
ending
and i think the answer is no anyway so
we'll move on hold your head up high you
denizens of quahog
you've given a hearty effort through two
rounds but unfortunately
it is once again the simpsons who are
celebrating a round two win
at flaming moe's please take the fries
off moe's head they're very hot
simpsons gets the win and goes up two
nothing over the griffins
i'm a billionaire
round three iconic characters
since math is nearly impossible after
eighth grade i've taken the liberty of
making the calculation that these two
shows have combined for over 50 seasons
worth of quality entertainment
and what is the secret sauce that keeps
us coming back for more adventures in
springfield and quahog
why it's the town's citizens that make
those communities whole
of course starting with the namesake
family in the simpsons it's hard to
imagine a more iconic cast of characters
all under one roof than homer marge and
their shorts eating
sacks breathing passy sucking kids
taking a cue from sitcoms since the dawn
of time
it's marge that truly runs the homestead
as she deftly sidesteps the tom fullery
from her sophomoric husband
all while mothering three kids to
various degrees of success
that sound familiar family guy the real
achievement in that is how much more we
still connect with homer and marge
than virtually any other television
couple before or since
lucy and desi had their moments but the
simpsons parents have us running the
full gamut of emotions
just watching them try to keep their
home ship as tight as can be
always be yourself you want to be sad
honey be sad
we'll write it out with you if the
simpsons sinks its teeth into the mom
rolls the roost premise
family guy just bites it right off lois
is clearly in charge despite peter's
insanely juvenile shenanigans
the biggest difference being that the
simpsons usually attempt
some sort of teaching moment for homer
within the episode for peter
it's usually a quick mia culpa without
him ever really learning a lesson
whatever in both families their
three-child household featured one kid
that took off with the masses
thanks to their barely network tv
appropriate behavior and
merchandisable catchphrases i did i just
invent a word
merchandisable bart simpson knows a
little something about that
his famous catchphrases like don't have
a cow man largely inspired the family
guy's baby stewie to exclaim
with the deuce for the very first time
and while the simpsons young and maggie
has
barely a word in the show's history i'm
willing to bet she's already more astute
than chris griffin
as for megan lisa well as much as homer
can be sometimes intimidated by lisa's
remarkable intellect he still allows her
to feel loved and appreciated
meg uh not so much i fought it in your
cereal family guys starring homestead
might not be quite on a par with the
simpsons
however that doesn't include the pets
brian griffin scores major points as a
dog who can not only talk
but is one of the best parts of the show
whether it's him and stewie going on
misadventures
or brian's pseudo-intellectual abilities
getting him in
over his head pseudo-intellectual was
definitely a word that brian would use
to sound smart like i just did neither
one of us actually know what it means
i've actually been re-reading a lot of
books recently
i mean what's a rainbow's process two
parts rain
one part sun so let's move out of the
home and into the streets of these towns
to find the true
spice of these respective shows one of
the biggest attractions of both programs
week after week
is seeing who else is going to pop in to
offer a witty line or a juicy subplot
peter's drinking buddies do more than
that sometimes much
much more than that on a regular basis
joe cleveland and quagmire round out the
four musketeers
and their combined idiocy is frequently
a riot that is equal parts offensive
and hilarious i'd give them the point
over homer's regular drinking buddies
although barney gumbel and bartender mo
sizlak certainly have provided
more than their share of giggles over
the decades in fact since
so many of the townsfolk and quahog have
roots in similar characters from the
simpsons
let's see how they fare in a few
head-to-head matchups
mayor adam west versus mayor joe is i a
tight race indeed
joe quimby is a hilarious farce of a
kennedy but isn't quite as regular and
nowhere near as random
as adam west for sheer surprise as to
what's going to spill out of his mouth
next
i'm going with the former batman nobody
messes with adam we moving on to evil
billionaires we have montgomery burns
taking on carter pewterschmidt
even family guy jokes about how carter
sounds exactly like dr
hartman and while i am giving hartman
the nod over the simpsons doctors
this is easily a win for mr boo earns
carter has some great one-liners as he
staunchly refuses to accept change or
progress
but mr burns's devious side stories have
given
simpsons fans some of the most memorable
moments in the history of the show
from three-eyed fish to getting shot to
blocking out the sun
mr burns takes the cake plus he's the
reason we know smithers
appoo at the quickie mart is a staple of
past seasons but recently came under
fire with the great documentary the
trouble with that poo
it's a well-reasoned argument that the
character is a little more than just a
tired stereotype
so i can dock the simpsons some points
for being offensive although being
offensive seems to be a central goal to
most family guy jokes
nice throw casey anthony i'll give
newscasters to tom tucker and old creeps
to herbert
big celebrities are definitely led by
troy mcclure and real celebrities
well let's just say the simpsons has had
some of the most famous folks ever to
walk the earth be honored as a guest on
their show
family guy has adam west and a bunch of
fake voices we think
family guy loves making fun of my other
sport stand up comedy
everyone from quagmire to brian to an
actual lower torso has attempted telling
jokes on stage
and while it almost always hits home for
me no one singular force has emerged in
quahog to rival the ultimate entertainer
in springfield
krusty the clown the simpsons writers
love utilizing krusty for any and all
showbiz related gripes and it's a treat
for the audience
every time we could go on for days and
i'd love to do an entire versus episode
on who would win a winner take all brawl
between groundskeeper willie and ernie
the chicken
but the recurring theme in this round
seems to be that the simpsons
tend to have more fleshed out characters
even with less screen time
than some of their family guy
contemporaries and would we have many of
those lovable quahog side players
without the simpsons creating those
archetypes even the nicest neighbor in
the world ned flanders could see that
once again
the simpsons get the win in round three
they're up three nothing and family guy
is still looking for a leg to hump to
get a dry martini
[Music]
round four best episodes so i've spent
the better part of this here
program yapping about legacy time
influence and all that other jazz that
makes bleeding gums murphy smile
but in this round it's about the cream
of the crop the top of the heap the eric
roberts starring in
best of the best i'll take a smattering
of each show's most beloved 22-minute
chapters and see who has what it takes
to get a point
we'll start with the show that is still
looking to get on the scoreboard
as a fan of family guy for its entire
run yes i did rush out to circuit city
and buy the first dvd set
or maybe it was borders i can't remember
the show has been through two main
phases phase one only lasted for maybe
two seasons where most episodes would
attempt some sort of heartfelt
resolution after all the wackiness it
ensued
kind of like that other famous fox
cartoon phase two
is still running strong to this day
where no actual emotions need apply
and we instead rely on a week-long break
to rectify all of the insanity and
offensiveness we just witnessed
both phases have some gems but the way
this show kicked off with its premiere
episode
is definitely one of the best in its
storied history taking the ball from
john elway's swan song immediately after
super bowl 33
family guy debuted with high-flying
fast-paced cutaway loaded jokes that saw
peter
actually end up at the big game not
since the hbo show dream on
remember that kids brian benben anyone
had the world witness so many random
jokes and references sprinkled into a
sitcom format
the only issue with that premise was the
incredibly high borrowed set for the
rest of the season
nothing else in season one could match
the potency of its kickoff
an episode so famous in family guy war
that a decade later
another family guy would see stewie and
brian go back in time to witness
those events all over again deaths being
laid up with a busted ankle at the
griffin residence was another early
highlight in season two
as was the very first peter versus the
chicken battle
that same year the show gradually became
more risque with the humor it was
attempting even having the network pull
the plug on airing season threes
when you wish upon a weinstein whether
you consider this humor to be pushing
the envelope or
spilling the contents of the envelope
all over the floor once family guy
returned thanks to overwhelming demand
it was a very different show from when
it began but the comedic genius of seth
macfarlane and company was still
evident as seen in episodes like rhodes
of the multiverse where stewie and brian
stumble upon
alternate universes including one where
the role of dogs and humans are reversed
a running gag that has lasted since
opening night would be stewie doing his
damnedest to kill his mom
lois this storyline headlined the epic
two-parter stewie kills lois slash
lois kills stewie family guy loves every
opportunity
to experiment with different
storytelling scenarios like when there's
a murder mystery at a creepy mansion
a la clue or when they do a fan mail
episode that features a few short
vignettes
the chances they take don't always pay
off especially with a few inexplicably
long sequences of musical numbers
but when they do it produces some of the
finest work in franchise history
like in season two the road to rhode
island
brian heads to la to retrieve stewie but
the duo was forced to travel back across
the country primarily
by train where they put aside their
adversarial nature
to perform a memorable and shockingly
heartfelt tune
on top of a moving locomotive i'm with
an intellectual
who craps inside his pants how dare you
it that episode is a perfect summation
of mcfarland's love of show tunes and
his biting wit
and might just be the best work family
guy has yet to accomplish
but it'd also be remiss if i didn't say
there's a few more episodes that always
seem to happen
when the power goes out
[Music]
now look i'm a huge star wars hawk and
making fun of my beloved saga
has proven to be a tricky task over the
years spaceballs and countless other
parodies have done a magnificent job at
this
but only the great live show star wars
in 30 minutes and
family guy actually got official praise
from the creator himself
mr george lucas the original trilogy got
the family guy treatment kicking off
with blue
harvest and to this day seeing han peter
and chewie brian trying to wedge a
couch into the millennium falcon during
a death star shootout tickles me like
few gags ever have
ah for christ oh it's wedged it's wedged
spawned only 10 years earlier than
family guy yet from an entirely
different
era would be the simpsons a show whose
animation quality improved dramatically
in its formative years
to quickly deliver so many great
episodes that fans to this day
still hold up as the gold standard if
family guy had
trouble following its debut night the
simpsons might still be trying to figure
out how to top its first
decade in that time the show solidified
its perfect blend of humor and family
in a time when many parents in schools
wanted to ban the simpsons from their
precious children's minds
the show was somehow teaching us all how
vital a family can be
even one that is severely dysfunctional
and has a kid who says i'm bart simpson
who the hell are you
season two is the way we was paints a
sweet portrait of homer and marge's
courtship
and even though it was somewhat
retconned many years later it still
holds up as proof that an animated show
can make us howl with laughter
and tug on our heartstrings just be
careful using an onion ring as an
engagement band
all you new couples out there take note
the simpsons could do straightforward
episodes loaded with cameos like homer
at the bat
where mr burns recruits an actual big
league team to juice up his company
squad
as long as they shave their sideburns or
it could go more off the walls is when a
guy claiming he's michael jackson shows
up in springfield
he was actually a bricklayer from
paterson new jersey
it's your birthday but the show might be
at its best when it's following the
loose storyline of another classic
such as deep space homer a space odyssey
or when mr burns re-examines his
childhood a la
citizen kane with rosebud and i'd have
to point towards a classic sideshow bob
appearance in cape fear based on the
you get it while family guy is
rightfully celebrated for being able to
incorporate sweeping musical numbers in
its madcap mayhem
it was once again the simpsons who um
did it first one of the all-time great
episodes ties in the music man for marge
versus the monorail a traveling swindler
voiced by the irreplaceable phil hartman
proposes a monorail for springfield
and hilarious singing chaos ensues if
we're talking about all-time great
episodes for these two factions i'd be
remiss to not point out their friendly
rivalry
crossovers that might have seen a few
hatchets buried
even as they took a lot of shots at one
another but for my money the best
episode in either franchise
is another crossover event when jon
lovitz is the critic
made his way to springfield for a film
festival everyone in town
seemingly submitted a short film and the
variety of movies is a perfect
representation of the varying ways
the simpsons can get a rise out of us
there's a simple approach with a man
getting hit in the groin with a football
starring george c scott next up is a
high concept tragic play
pulled off by barney gumbel family guy
has grown into a show that excels at
being hilariously offensive and
increasingly
unsympathetic to its own characters but
the simpsons best episodes prove
that you can do some of that without
losing all of your animated humanity
no that's not the crowd booing our
beloved springfield residents
they are saying boo earns the simpsons
wins another round
and remain perfect through four can
family guy finally get a w in the last
round
it is after all the wild card round
highly hope
excellent all right here comes the wild
card round
what makes mark laugh harder i'm
very selfish yep family guy gets one
more crack at avoiding the first ever
skunk in versus
history and the odds are decent based on
how many knees i've slapped over the
years
giggity-eying to myself this round is as
simple as it sounds because after all
the decades and cultural influence and
controversies and salary negotiations
why do these shows ever get created in
the first place easy
matt greening and seth macfarlane just
wanted to entertain us
and i think i speak for literally all of
my comedian brethren when i say that
without the simpsons
we might not have developed a sense of
humor at all much less made a career out
of it
and from the first time i stumbled upon
a show in sixth grade that had a lot of
animated characters wives crack into
each other
it became a weekly check-in as to just
how funny a premise could be
how far a joke could be taken and how to
wrap it all up in a concise
storytelling narrative and when i looked
around the living room i'd see this show
was not only able to make me laugh
but my parents siblings and all my
friends whose parents didn't let them
watch it so they came over to my house
for stovetop stuffing and
the first family of springfield seeing
bart reenact the opening of raiders of
the lost ark complete with homer
as the giant boulder remains one of the
hardest laughs my family ever
shared and to spread that lucasfilm
wealth evenly
homer accidentally ruins the empire
strikes back for a line of excited
moviegoers
and it pretty much had the entire clan
of ellis's in
stitches and it was also a hysterical
harbinger as to spoil alerts
that are now all too common to our movie
going experience thank you mr blow the
picture for me but even after giving the
simpsons well-earned victories in every
round thus far
i can also admit that my personal
feeling of the show is that
it has never regained its comedic gold
found in its first decade
heyday maybe it was the writing staff or
the premises
or my personal theory that losing phil
hartman took away a little bit of the
luster from the show
don't get me wrong i still tune in
occasionally and find some great nuggets
in there
and i can still go back and re-watch
classic episodes and have my youthful
guffaws once again
but the simpsons simply doesn't work for
me as well as it once did
conversely family guy has become my
go-to for late night comfort food
company whereas the simpsons made my
entire family laugh
i have other fond memories of being in
my freshman dorm after that super bowl
howling with laughter in a packed room
experiencing family guy
for the first time with my college
buddies true story my pal jeff
laughed so hard he dropped a bottle of
carbonated liquid onto his laptop
completely destroying it
that only added to the rest of us
laughing at family guy and then also
jeff sorry buddy i can readily
acknowledge that family guy isn't for
everyone and frequently goes
way too far in its attempt to be
shocking or controversial but when it
hits me in the funny bone
i giggle in ways that no other show has
ever been able to produce
and the best part is it can come from
anywhere at any time
it might be stewie or brian often an
adventure or lowest chastising peter or
any one of the random inhabitants of
quahog
stepping into the spotlight on any given
sunday let me be crystal clear about
this
we don't get family guy without the
simpsons and we probably don't get south
park or rick and morty or
much else of what modern comedy is
without ned flanders his neighbors
but if i need a laugh right now the show
i'm leaning on is
family guy it can sometimes annoy me or
even off-put me
but a vast majority of the time it hits
me right in the funny bone so hard
i wake up the dog and she's good at
sleeping
family guy wins the wild card round and
forevermore can brag
that it took a point off the simpsons
which is kind of like saying you lost to
michael jordan in one on one but the
score
was 11-1 you don't care about losing
but you'll tell that story of getting a
point for the rest of your life
and for the record yes i actually do
slap my knee watching family guy
nothing else has ever conjured that
response in me i laugh so hard
i hit myself that is doing the job well
i want to hear more music about pie
it's a wonderful day for pie
so there you have it kids a sincere
thanks to family guy for closing it out
strong
but it is nonetheless a record win for
the simpsons
roadhouse we've had a few lopsided
versus episodes before
but a four to one blowout is uncharted
territory
good on you dear viewer for hanging in
even when you already knew the outcome
my opinion has been stated but now it's
up to you which show do you like better
and why drop me a line on social media
anytime
at mark ellis live or hit us up at
rotten tomatoes and defend your position
or just hire lionel hutz to represent
you in this all-important court of
cartoon comedy concoctions
just be ready when mr kool-aid pops in
until next time
i'm mark ellis who the hell are you
[Music]
you